[Music]
somebody in the my online beginner
series course was asking me about the
difference between knobs and loops in
regards to you know the possibility of
developing repetitive strain issues in
the hands and wrists and I think it's a
great question so I thought I'd make the
answer for everybody I don't you know as
you know I make a lot of videos for
everybody but some stuff's only in the
online courses and there is going to be
a difference between a loop and a knob
you know or double looped em but also
how you use the grip is going to make
probably a bigger difference than which
grip you're using so a lot of my place
spinning life I've used a single loop
now these play are great because I've
got both here now what I'll often do is
all I can pinch and then fold over my
fingers and then it's inches on my
fingers a bit and that means if I want
to I completely relaxed my hand so one
thing is relaxing the muscles the other
thing is how you're moving your your
articulations so if you have a hammer
say doing this with your wrist it
doesn't matter whether you had a loop or
a knob that will likely lead to problems
in your wrist if you're going to that
extreme motion so it's this habit of
being gentle with my range of motion
that'll be more protective of my wrists
than the grip itself but I'm using the
knob it's almost the same I can it's a
bit of a sticky knob knobs you from
speakers calm so I can gently have them
my fingers and I'm still quite relaxed
also I'm only going through a gentle
range of motion so if I had the sand
knob but I was really gripping it and
I'm really going like this with my
wrists again that will lead the problems
and the knob isn't causing the problem
it's my gripping of it little so whether
it's a loop or knob the trick is to be
relaxed as much as you can with
with your muscles and when possible use
a gentle range of motion rather than
extreme range of motion so that's the
best advice I can have other than it's
also good to shift things up I think
it's great to have two or three sets of
poi ones loops another set with knobs or
one set with both like this and then to
switch grips on a fairly regular basis
or you can switch which fingers you're
using with any giving grip because with
a knob I can be between these two
fingers which I can very easily switch
to holding it like that and it's been a
habit of mine for a while that as I'm
playing I'm just often switching same
thing for if using a loop won't always
put it on the same fingers maybe
sometimes on these two fingers sometimes
on this finger sometimes I'll dangle it
on my ring finger and hold it here again
it's just a habit because I know that if
I'm changing hand gripping my employee
regularly that I'm distributing that any
stress on the body between different
digits and I've I've trouble with my
shoulder but I've never after years in
your suspending I've never had trouble
with my wrist or fingers this this is
all good so that's what I can say yeah
just play it up experiment and make that
a lifelong habit to be switching your
grip a little bit and with a little luck
you won't have any problems
ALPA help
you
[Music]